[Music]
from warner brothers studios in
hollywood it's the conan audiency awards
celebrating excellence in the sitting
and looking arts
here now is your host conan o'brien
thank you
thank you so much
what a thrill
to be here
for the audience awards
now for a night this important i think i
need to dress the part bruce do you mind
[Applause]
[Music]
jealous ladies it's that quick and
simple
[Laughter]
oh
let's look at the audiency award itself
don't you wish you had this
it's a golden man
a golden man with no genitals sitting in
a crappy chair and this can be yours
all right our first audiency award is
for the best impression of a celebrity
and the audience he goes to the person
in seat 5d for their impression of
apple's pc guy
[Applause]
the next audience the award is also for
best impression of a celebrity in the
audience he goes to the person in seat
16e for their impression of miley cyrus
[Music]
very good
[Music]
are you chewing gum
chewing gum at my show
the last audiency award for best
impression goes to the person in seat 7j
for their impression of a police chief
on vacation
[Music]
you won
you did it
this is yours chief
a long hard-earned vacation you've got
chief
all right the next
the next audiency goes to the person in
seat 15 m it's the award for the
audience member most likely to own his
own pool cue
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the next audience he goes the person in
seat 11k it's the award for the audience
member most likely to have majored in
glassblowing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the next audiency
oh well i alienate you all one by one
the next audiency goes to the person in
seat 7f it's the award for the audience
member most likely to get out of a
speeding ticket
[Music]
[Applause]
i noticed
so many guys in the crowd are like
where's
where is she
where is he
our next audience he goes to the
creepiest audience member and the award
goes to the guy staring at me right now
from under the seats
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she's here and you're looking at me
all right